[Music] citizens of the reject Nation it's me
Terry ericon hello with this guy and Flash Gordon
we're going to watch now you see me too today
I'm starting I'm doing a sing intro do we love
it or do we hate it I personally love it but I'm
biased because I love everything you would say so
Andrew's the bestest listen guys you got to make
sure you like this video you got to type in your
comments to be nice cool kind also don't forget
to ring the bell ring the bell thanks prepper for
helping us edit down these videos also we call
you super sexy if you get on patreon you go to
patreon.com support the real rejects also you can
sync up with your own copy watch ni me to like
basically the whole thing with me and Andrew okay
and also Greg and John offer exclusive highlights
and watch alongs over there on patreon so get
down get with it we call you super sexy if you
know what's up you got anything to say before
we get into this Andre I do you know I saw in
the comments of the our first video that uh they
had a missed opportunity with the title here they
said instead of calling it now you see me too
they should have said now you don't I tend to
agree with that one now you don't I like that
I love it we're going to get into it let's do
it tonight Lial strike is making another sad
attempt for retention by performing what he
calls an impossible feat thinks he's able to
escape dad oh is this more backstory into uh
now see that seat there it's the best seat
in the house is strike the kind of magician
who could pull this off I don't want you
to go this is what I do going to prove all
those nay was wrong did they recast besides
I always keep something up my sleeve okay how
many seconds 300 300 maybe a few less cuz
I think this is Mark ruffo's character the
kid right but I thought Elias kotas was
the the dad and the first one must have
recast whoa 298 299
3003 304 I would have been worried after
200 it's interesting in the first film Isa
Fisher she almost actually drowned in that that
one water that's crazy I didn't know [Music]
that a little kid's a good actor people see the
horsemen as Noble Robin hoods or are they common
thieves depends on your point of view here's what
you know they robbed a bank in Paris from a stage
in Las Vegas here's our recap they fleed an
insurance magnet of hundreds of millions of
dollars and disappeared from a roof in New York M
cocaine yay here's what you don't know they left
one man behind fra holding the bag me me when you
emerge I will be there because mark my words you
will get what's coming to you how is he able to
record this in jail instead of a shank he got a
camera
welcome Daniel Atlas is that like a well I asked
to see the face behind all of this you've asked
many questions and registered many complaints huh
we've been living and hiding you feel it is you
who should be leading the horsemen not Dylan
if that is what you desire stay the course we
have a new mission for the horsemen Dylan has
a plan and we'll gather you together soon that
spooky North Carolina Florida still infiltrating
the FBI it's about the horsemen there's chatter
going on about the horsemen and something
happening with OCTA the giant software I
know what OCTA is might be Daniel Atlas maybe
mer mckin emails cell phones any transcripts
pigeons magicians work with pigeons oh that's
true they do this pigeon right here there's
Daniel Atlas same pigeon on a sailboat with a guy
that looks just like Meritt mckin it's [__] did
you sing a new song sees right through him
yeah he's like he clearly he watched the
first movie yeah you don't know me but my first
year in the academy you gave a talk oh snap you
talked about a moral compass about how you
believed in yours immutably and I thought to
myself that guy I want to be that guy and now
a pigeon you should see him when he's angry
she she's great the problem is when you're two
people people at the same time one of them is
bound to trip the other and when that happens
I will be there do not yeah he's really on to
him huh that is an interesting position
to like follow that throughout the film
like now knowing the Twist and seeing how he's
able to balance right who are you what are you
doing in my actually fny how did you get
into my I love her Lizzy kapan I actually
just I'm rewatching Smallville so she was
in two episodes in seasons 1 and two and
she was also in Hot Tub Time Machine many
of I made myself in the neighborhood and
now I'm here oh no no no I recognize you you
did that bgrade geek magic thing didn't you
you pulled a hat out of the rabbit a hat out
of the rabbit that's right no it was actually
kind of disgusting do that trick so if you
wouldn't mind crawling out from under my couch
and Tada now I'm sitting over here huh
you passed your audition what is it that
you want well I wanted to meet you I want to
be a part of the eye like you and Meritt and
Jack I know that Jack is alive what is this
Cher hitch yeah I'm so sorry that Henley left
you oh God sorry that's actually a little better
believe she was pregnant in real life at the time
during this movie yeah here's what's going
to happen uh you're going to stay here and
stop talking and I'm going to make a phone
call and in about 5 minutes some people are
I had a feeling that was Shake shacky yet
this movie makes me want it the momentum of
the car do the work for you mhm this last one
I call the star I thought it was all in the
hips wrong movie now you want to see a thing of
beauty I do indeed here you go and bingo bango
bongo that's good not bad when it comes to
hypnotism the student has almost become the master
I like confidence you have the better teachers
you know you're right you're right your teacher
definitely doesn't know what he's doing by the
way was this your card yesterday fact it was is
that a physical effect that looked awesome I was
like did he legit learn card tricks for this movie
I would I mean I mean that is not easy to learn
Danny what's up man stare at the palm of your hand
and as your eyes change Focus you will begin to
notice everything cuz I'm not hypnotized it's not
working please don't become him do you think Lizzy
followed him somebody broke into my apartment some
amateur who knew everything about me everything
about Henley leaving everything about us that's
her oh or she already knew where they were what is
she doing here I'm the new Horseman I'm the girl
Horseman well Lulu's been on the Underground scene
for the last decade and I I think she has some
real talent and I'd like to try her on stage to
balance out the duo to balance out the doess the
issue is that we have been rehearsing for months
what it is you're going to keep working until we
work as a single organism I know I've heard you
say that I think what you're referring to is us
you know not you I'm getting my orders directly
from the eye you guys are this this amazing
tightnit family unit I'm a we are anything but
a family like wrong franchise octa's hosting the
launch of the NextGen cell phon they'll siphon
their users information to the black market
meaning OCTA selling privacy to up their profit
the eyes decided to expose fored our mission is
to hijack the show rehearsal is over guys so we're
in the sequel does that mean the group is going to
go through some kind of a turmoil we shall hope
for pure entertainment and drama purposes can't
have you texting tweeting recording or eating
security Memo from case himself we're all good
I'm heading to the control room all right thanks
J Atlas go no don't I what what's your problem ooh
that looks good what oh that was cool what shut
up that was awesome you see me now you don't you
understand sake just case uh John from legal just
need your signature for release thank you so much
thank you so much that is such a normal thing
where people in that position of power just
don't even oh nice don't even look at what they're
signing right buddy look I got a job to do I have
a job to do too so listen I'm going to need some
backup in security my name is thank you very much
I'm not this gu not calm down please hey what's
going on this is so elaborate I love it I'm not
him say here Evans metal facility Mark D stew hold
on seen this before in my amazing love that cannot
trust anybody in this city anymore you I want
to call my hey what's going on I want to call
my boss in this jacket hey hey make your phone
call that's your right that's my right what the
hell I'd love this is giving me like ocean 11
Vibes yeah I could see that so quick but it's
fun like that too yeah I can take over from here
Clark says you're on break who's Clark who's Clark
it's funny imagine if I told Roger that who the
hell is Roger is he going to do his hypnotist
trick on him you make me have to go to Brian
why are you I'll go straight through [Music]
oh oh god oh she was able to do the beheading
in uh in Jesse eisenberg's room so she's good
at doing that stuff by the flow of blood which
is fully fixable in the snack by focusing and
following which is why you're focusing on my
command the voice in your head this is that
voice oh W cool I felt like I was almost
hypnotized just listening to it the light
this is like Lizzy kaplan's character in party
down which is I've never seen such a good show I
quit all the people are like I just saw bone
oh oh gnarly you imagine if you're a customer
you saw that or a gas good morning octoly good
morning octoly I like his accent playing that
OCTA 8 is pure magic but the truth is that's
just one of those things I say I mean something
else when in fact here to fill you in on some of
my fabulous slies in hypocrisy curious what
he signed too earlier they are the world's
greatest magicians here to expose me for the
fraud I truly am oh the fraud I truly am wow
awesome oh that's a dope intro shut up that
was so cool he's mocked your privacy when you
signed uh probably without reading um the
terms and conditions of Oct what uh FBI is
here oh no B go to plan C4 hey boss I'm glad
you're here they have three plan C's and now
they're using a four so everything that he
had once considered private have a feeling
this movie is going to be built on plot twist
that he once considered private is now owned
some other magicians trying to upstand them the
Horseman like to say magic is about controlling
perception this is crazy we got to get everyone
to the other entrance let's go to the back no
Danny everyone get off the stage abort does
this feel like saw right now to you a little
bit yes the voice I this is just the plan
C4 and now for the big reveal have they
met their matches there's a fifth Horseman
FBI agent roads the FB Dylan who are you
sorry whoa yeah baby magic Now You See Me Now you
don't cool I want to that I
was going to say that looks fun
nice still looks fun where the
hell are we like can we get some
food first noodles look delicious why
are we here why am I freaking starving
see oh wa wait how did that happen that's
they're in another country because they
went down a apparently we're now surrounded
by Chinese food I think where we are right
now they don't refer to it as Chinese food
it's just called okay yeah how is that POS
they just went down a slide I believe in your
particular par the word is Magic I'm so I'm so
confused remember I told you about the guy who
screwed me out of everything this is my twin
brother Chase oh oh okay wait did you do this
oh my goodness and you know what they say what
happens in maau uh well I don't know the rest
of it cuz it's in Chinese uh hey thanks guys
hey thanks guys that's still like the thought
of that sliding down 20 to 30 seconds from New
York gets you into China I'm like how I wanted
him to explain like how it worked I had to some
trick cuz at first I thought maybe they just
built this within New York how does it feel
to be out of control perhaps for the first
time what do you want you're a fool agent
roads you always have been oh you're wondering
if I was behind the Horseman's recent tobacco
I'll let you work that out for yourself and I'm
not playing de it's not my game agent Road it's
yours do you think my cocaine had something
to do with it like he hired the new magician
I don't know it is very interesting because
you mentioned saw that he said this is not my
game it's yours and there's always one specific
person that has a game and now we know it's might
be mostly Dylan's just tell me how you did it
delivery guy came to your door about a month ago
Pizza okay d33 75 not even
close oh oh he hypnotized him oh he didn't
know his brother could do it so what he did
my little W mate is he uh downloaded all your
private information oh damn wow the hypnotist
was hypnotized all right so sorry yeah you
should be don't ever accuse me of betraying
us again okay he was hypnotized that's
I mean it's really not his I mean he's
probably just mostly apologizing for his crazy
brother I know but again that's not his fault
yeah who is this that's the most amazing room
I've seen in a minute what expel what I did not
know that he was in this well in as much as
a magician who pulls a rabbit from a hat is
working with that rabbit he knows a thing about
magic I believe he does yeah you're Walter Ma
you died a year ago yes an idea I got from you
Mr wer so weird to see him all there like this
you all want an audience I just want to be and
100% off the grid yeah because the grid is for
actual human beings would you like to know my
friends just how I got you here we know how you
did it no you don't serious strobe was a combo
Boral Beach as well as I said stop you may not
be having fun but I am H in your heightened state
of agitation you saw the simplest cues black tube
roof and your mind's filled in the rest the
tube you meant to go down was 20 ft to your
right okay but how does that explain how they
got to China contained letters pulsing the word
sleep oh and then they drove to China yeah it's
it's a it's a quick ride from New York to oh my
God I love this that's really creepy that's
like reminds me of The Hangover like the app
yeah okay so it was instantaneous for us yes
okay that makes that makes more sense why are
we here then well to start with the the man you
stole from last year turns out I had invested
quite a lot of money in some of his companies
so M cocaine Owen and I were like the Beatles
and like them we had a dream could we create
actual magic Owen wanted it for himself so
he humiliated Me by exposing my private files
to the board of directors you take a picture
of him while he was sleeping he goes around to
taking credit for a chip that's not just a key
to one computer but every computer system
on the planet oh that which includes your
targets a crew led by South African gangster
so how your team gets by security that's up
to you you just need to inspect it and steal
it that's it come on this is perfect for you
yeah we're stealing for Harry Potter guess now
it's starting to really feel like Oceans 11 I'm
not theing the thing for you not unless Dylan
tells me it's okay really actually we'll do it
we're in Mel the old magic store in the world
is here we'll get the supplies we need and uh
we'll do it he's been so Keen to be the leader of
the group too with there's going to be something
hidden he's got an ulterior motive I feel like
for doing it Oh you mean uh Jesse Eisenberg
yeah it's Morgan Freeman oh okay I didn't get
to finish my lobst just makes me very grumpy
okay let's cut the CRA Lobster in ja Lobster in
prison I don't even get Lobster here you Ed the
form 29 warrant to search my room you found a
connection between me and The Four Horsemen you
can take me out of here on a 24-hour leave I've
C you by the balls when your little Vendetta
ended with you putting me in jail 18 months ago
you stopped paying attention and that's where
you lost or you can make a deal with me and Save
The Four Horsemen that makes sense cuz his whole
purpose and being with Morgan Freeman stopping
him yeah we can't trust Walter okay the eye has
a history in maau they're the only ones we can
trust yeah but even if they succeed for Walter
do you think he's still going to let them live
plan man don't know whoa cool shop I love magic
shops yeah um we we need some things custom
made actually by tomorrow we're kind of in a
rush and uh you have no idea what I'm talking
about do you what is she doing welcome to Ian
my name's Lee notle what got you okay look is
that the ACT ctor from Green Hornet who played
KO so we need a keplinger hold out and we also
need a roughing fluid a Sonata gimmick sleeves
tracks that's all in plastic yeah I'm pretty
sure that is KO from Green Hornet my green
wants to know why plastic uh we're going through
a very sensitive metal detector so plastic nothing
metal you say it's just because you are talking
slowly and moving your hands doesn't mean she
can subtly understand English so sorry he RAC hey
can I use your phone it's kind of important sure I
don't know howse thanks even if it's crust country
that's how we've been contacting the eye Dylan's
not going to like this not really concerned with
what Dylan likes okay I'm doing this for us he's
going rogue I want to know who he's talking to
in the eye you don't think it's his you don't
think it's his father his father right said I have
something up my sleeve remember I mean it could be
my sources telling me your Horsemen are in maow
it's n of your business who your s es there some
old friends are you surprised he's still able to
use his FBI badge and all that after yeah cuz he
was just I mean he was outed I would think it
would be like everything revoked and everywhere
like Dylan is wanted he's not allowed to use his
FBI bad any I agree every girl I get close to I
end up taking their trust and then their wallet
you take their wallet did you take his Chase as
you stare into my eyes you will find that you want
to sleep when you wake you will beg for Merritt's
forgiveness and realize that you will never
be half the man that he is hey you had a good
teacher so very very sorry about how pathetic
your pure Bo is hey ah dang it do you think by
the end of the film he'll get it he'll be able
to do it yeah he must question is on who Morgan
Freeman maybe I'd be lying if I said I didn't
think this road would lead to the great wizard
behind the curtain and in theend end I might
get to see his face listen to me I broke you
out of there we're not changing the terms now you
put me there yeah because you deserve to be there
listen I did not kill your father is he really
gone 30 years and the greatest long game magic
trick ever created just to put me behind bars I
don't know what you're talking about you're lying
it was an empty experience just like a poison
you think you're luring me into a trap you're
not my only concern is the health and well-being
of the horsemen and you're going to leave me to
them and if you don't I promise you you're going
to end up far worse than in some cushy jail cell
somewhere I was going to say that did look I mean
he get Lobster it's a nice jail I mean that take
me to prison if I get that if I get those AC you
know accomodations what if the horsemen don't
actually need you to save them well then he's
out of a job prediction do you think his dad's
alive or no I don't know just that line feel
like the line I think up my sle like why did
he wait so long wanted his son to to go through
a psychotically torturous lifestyle had his Pike
he's RSVP with what looks like a couple of members
of his security detail apparently he travels with
a different bimbo every week H I wonder which one
of us gets to play the bimbo Woody arson you trust
your people implicitly you will have them take
care of everything and you will wait in the car
and eyes open wide awake so glad you could make
it I trust my people implicitly but I'm sure
you'd like to see it for yourself check the build
quality also fine ah love that okay you'll have
to remove all your metal watches Rings excuse me
for asking where might I have seen you before no
yeah that's right they're famous the book jacket
oh thank you so much uh which book they they've
been uh so many I got your email Dr malakis you
had a query about our ability to maintain Quantum
coherence at room temperature I did I sent it so
uh what gives actually the grownups are having a
meeting Buffy you hold on to that shut your mouth
hold my gum every seventh grader know the second
law of Thermodynamics all ordered systems tend
toward disorder Disorder so I'm going to ask you
one more time sir what gives I'm sold we do
it's actually topological Quantum order the
emergence of quantum effects on a macroscopic
level so that is in fact what gives that makes
sense damn that thing really goes off
[Music] this is the housing oh snap 820 million
cubic miles of dapic resonance cool oh my God
I must be allergic to something this room is
hermetically sealed I'm allergic to hermetic
seals is this part of the plant it's got to
be need to be sterile if you intend to get
any closer ah okay any contamination have to stay
away from the in work going on Mission Impossible
awesome it's pressured too like this is very
time sensitive situation yeah nice searching
please that is so
brilliant
nice brilliant cool oh oh well done
well done well done well done that is
sick oh my God whoa hey walk on my [Music]
own y I want to know how
they got the camera in there
yeah hey do that myself you just met
man this is such a a wellmade it's very
creative do you have anything I don't know
can't trust anybody they're clean yeah do
your final checks and get them out of here
oh my God I that was a lot of tension and
suspense oh my God goodness whoa you see in the
court oh they're still checking that it just
doesn't end thanks pal appreciate that how
many times did they have to practice that a
million you guys are pretty serious
about your security huh D joh okay
uh sir I think uh I think you
still have my wallet remember
I uh I gave it to you when I came
in he's going to throw it into the
[Music]
wallet
whoa this TCH everything right Dam remember he
could barely fling it at the beginning with Haron
now he's skipping cards man so now you know
that Dave Franco has to get the hypnotizing
down at some point cuz one of them's gotten the
other down if anyone asked me to skip rocks I'm
going to be like no we're going to learn to
skip cards that that probably was my favorite
scene in the movie yeah that was awesome God
I can't even imagine how long that took to
film excuse me have you seen these people says
her grandson spoke to their leader you speak
man so many twists and
that's why he worked for the
FBI [Music] whoa the the back room magic shop is
way cooler I was going to
say this place is massive
awesome the audience thought he just oh
okay oh that's got to be crazy for him of
his dad's stuff and the case the safe I believe
that's the prototype for the one your father had
memories your father used to come here when
you were young the safe was made from cheap
metal now it bow you all always had something
up his sleeve unless he reached the limit of
his capabilities no it didn't now I really
feel like he's still alive my grandmother
has something you might want because they said
it bowed but that didn't he had several of Le
made well if there's one thing
we've learned from so far in
these two films nothing is as it seems his dad's
watch wait if that's that's his dad's watch
that he was wearing when he said look at our
watches together all right has he escaped H oh
man 24-hour plan turned into oh man I didn't
know he was a magician too I just thought
he exposed them if you really sit around
studying those videos probably get pretty good
at it I'm assuming it was actually not you who
walked into Newberg federal prison and walked
out 30 minutes later with thus Bradley he used
your ID oh cuz he used a different ID that's why
okay we we were wondering about that oh still I
would have thought they would have had like wanted
pictures of his face but it's prison and they're
like probably don't want a lot of T in there this
is the last place we think he's going to visit I
guess hey I blew it I'm sorry okay I'm here to
help now okay we definitely don't need your help
no I'm in charge I'm meeting somebody from the eye
yeah now they agreed to meet meet me to exchange
this computer chip for our life backs Atlas give
me a stick you're not our leader anymore okay if
you really want to help us you would leave sure
that's the last we'll see of him or that just
could be part of their plan to be a ruse so
much fun know you'd be scurrying away from me
at the lab just to bring it to me here I don't
trust him and yours obviously is ego stay the
course great changes are in store trust that your
unique talents will not come recognized oh that
was him who telling you oh Meritt downloaded all
the files but how do you think we were able to
find him what you actually put your phone on was
a by wve siphon pad once again science beats magic
M ooh you really think I'm going to walk away from
you don't give me it all right don't
ever question me again Beat It Go To
Hell oh not the fishy
whoa y'all better watch out he's in the FBI okay
so he redeemed himself there that was pretty
good oh oh
damn whoa that was good that was really
good h notice he's got the color green
Tara I do he's hulking it slightly
oh little cute bunny whoa see later
dude oh and Jesse Eisenberg
said he's not a [Music]
magician
yes [Music]
waa a now he's caught chill watch the pretty
birdie fly oh no doesn't work on me not even
as a distraction ow good job nice to be involved
so they're working together I just saw Dylan um
something happened here what happened atas I
I don't know I don't know you got to rescue
him now sacrificed himself for you this is what
they want oh that's Li strik safe okay we got to
follow that truck they must have Dylan we don't
know how much time did they say that uh that
he's related to Mich Kane no oh I was thinking
maybe he was his son or something oh you I share
a very deep connection with my father like you
I'll stop at nothing to avenge any wrongs done
to him Oh you mean Harry Potter yeah oh yeah that
is Michael Kane's son yeah I believe mine's still
alive get him up okay so they did no no it's
not his father I think he he invested money
in that company right that and so they were close
oh okay I don't think it's his dad though so this
my cocaine when my father died your insurance
company denied my mother claims she died known
who your mother was once you made yourself
known it became very personal my son yeah
the sociopath oh okay okay there there you go
your Horsemen have it you will turn it and them
over to us no like any good leader he sacrificed
himself MH now they got to rescue him I want you
to know that when you're gone we're not going
to stop we're going to destroy everything you
believe in starting with the Horseman and ending
with the eye now then I I still think the ey is
his father is Mark ruffalo's father oh just
cuz that line trick up a trick up his sleeve
yeah this is to bring back
some childhood memories oh
God he's going to discover what
the trick up his sleeve is when
he's in that case oh boy and maybe
him having that card does he have
300 seconds to get out of there when
it's from in the water you shall SA
oh my goodness that would
be so scary that was a long
fall you got to stop breathe look around use
that card he has still still has a [Music] card
where is the trick up the sleeve oh
the watch to see if his dad's what
chicken you something I'm must
leave yes
okay yes all right oh and
it turns on [Music] amazing
oh cool it's like a blueprint for how to escape
yeah come on hulky boy Bo you can do it no
Mark what you did it yeah right okay good
there' still be so much pressure and swim
back up that' be terrible I wish I could
dredge from the muck of my soul one Speck of
remorse but I can't they stole my money is he
with Morgan Freeman where are the horsemen there
need to be a do are all too powerful to keep them
out of the Limelight for long if they don't
make themselves known you will find yourself
in in a very similar position it's always the
central theme in these two films about [Music]
revenge who that they jess Jessie yeah I mean
he did save him earlier from Walter CPR y'all
come on now oh okay okay thanks for pulling
me out seriously you guys something's not
right what's wrong what it's fake what what what
there's a quote um a magician's greatest power in
his empty Fist and the Very idea that he could
convince the world that he is in fact carrying
with him a secret it's line shrink he has to
be the a what does a stick do the stick can un
encode anything it can open up a back door into
any computer we not only make him think that we
have it but that we're going to use it to expose
and destroy him him yeah use his own ego against
him heck yeah of us but we also need supplies
right and resources and probably more than five
people go to the magic shop really think you don't
have help oh she speaks English of course the fool
is the most powerful card are you part of the
eye yes you've each doubted our existence if
we indeed were watching but now we have resources
and help so who's in I'm in yeah I'm in yay it's
going to be the greatest magic trick ever yeah
we were tricked I was exposed and brought back
from the dead so we thought that we'd do the
same thing to the person who did it to us get
my father my father we too will bring someone
back from the dead this card can hack into any
system on the planet including ours they have it
why wouldn't they use it threat is real so how do
we stay ahead of them we need to get to London by
midnight anything that says Horsemen brags about
seeing a Horseman time and bundle them anyone
who wants to work station throughout the city
so they can meet anywhere in 60 seconds do what
I say cuz I'm also Harry Potter hello hey cool
my name Jack Wilder they are so damn famous yeah
let me demonstrate Whoa man would you mind being
my queen don't worry I promise you there's a
50% chance we'll get her back after the show
that's better than zero tonight I am going to
make something fly using actual magic I'm going
to take a very large vessel I'm going to make it
fly over there and land on the temp can you handle
that no keep your eye on the queen if you have a
location it's Jack Wilder and here we go switch
she's on the left yeah where is she I mean she's
supposed to to be on the left but but she might
not be thank you very much uh how did he do that
not not not my girl 100% your girl but just in
this situation it's like I don't find your trick
amusing find the pattern you do that and you'll be
able to cut them off before they get to their
final trick like this they're beating them at
their own game I love how he has like those little
British stacks of snacks always wherever he goes
okay everybody we're getting a patn the hell is
that freeze that and zoom in how did he survive
he's dead we watched him drown how the hell did
this happen what are we going to do about him we
going to stop him dad for the record I never loved
the safe idea easier to say that in hindsight I'm
going to try to control the weather yeah um oh
this I'm interested I'm not just going to make
it clear up no no no no no I'm going to make it
actually stop oh the reverse the reverse rain
yeah whoa yeah that would make me stop making
out with someone too if I saw that not me make
it go up yeah the reverse rain we saw that in the
magic shop awesome I had a feeling that was going
to come back around that's so dope s show me the
lady you know what I'm actually starting to feel
kind of bad what you know it's unfortunate that
it's the wrong kind of attention how what's so
cute let's kill him right I don't like that idea
I'm on my way I'll see you there Lula stand by
all right I don't know just go and see cool
where you headed Tower Blendon tower bridge
near Tower Bridge bro if there's any chance
of us ever having a relationship there's not
I know where you going I have a feeling that
he was expecting him to come for some reason I
don't know why yeah meet me at the r point now
was that an act of God no that was an act of
me and of strob lights and Rain machines cuz
you're going to need to know all of that for
the final cool you're going to have to wait to
find out I know I'm sorry I'm sorry I love you
all
[Applause] whoa what that is so you got to say
regardless of what you think of these films the
magic is always entertaining so good where the
hell are the horsemen well you can chase them
all you want you're just going to wind up
holding your own Tails or you can let them
come to you chase their own Tails like lobster
tails what the hell happened my goddamn brother
happen don't worry about it we just got to
get to the destination Lula can you handle
that thing I can ride it have you asked
the guys that question or just me [Music]
uhoh oh no oh crap get uhoh leave no one behind
that's the break that's guess you'll figure it out
come on follow that's it it's very easy it's not
hard to learn how to ride a bike or anything ow
[Music] ooh
nice okay those things are really
dangerous is the eye going to have to
save them one of you has something we
[Music]
require they switched the handcuffs I couldn't
they did something you make it almost too easy
I me even your hilarious attempts to make
yourselves unpredictable just follow the
same pattern each time set up set up set up
big reveal I almost feel like they wanted to
get caught well that will be a big reveal and
it will come now start with her Danny give him
the [Music] card I wonder what happened to the
original one you should have planed this is the
both of us we this is clearly this is planned
out this is a setup right yeah they're like I
just have to say congratulations it's real what
you say it's real what is he talking about well
done my boy is he lying that it's real I'm so
I don't I'm so lost right now which is good is
the most expensive bottle $1.2 million and I
saved it just for this occasion that is such
a waste of money same bottle Liquor Shack 700k
you got what you wanted mean you're letting us
go what should we do toss him out he's really
a good brother I came into the world with the
wrong family but I'm leaving with the right
one this is how I you out of the oh it it
has to be there has to be like parachutes
they have I guess we're going to find out
yeah he's like touching him each
one on the back the brother I feel
like hypnotized he's yeah or he's do
he did something to help save jeez
what the hell no is it supposed to
taste like that is it piss it's all
setup fool yeah okay so the screen that
they were reading said that it was real
oh oh oh what this is crazy that's
awesome what what how did they do that
Heman that was quite a trick that was awesome I do
that made them go to a certain location and
then do that I'm s did they do that how do
they move the the plane you feel pretty good
about yourself man you predicted it correctly
the TS stroke of midnight New Year's Eve happy
New Year oh now he's extra exposed unbelievable
we are moving now all back up into position set
you're staying here course H oh oh he's got a
trick up my sleeve literally up my sleeve
he has brought himself back from the death
he revealed someone and he is our friend and
he is our leader Dylan sh get over here good
leader hello hello I like how Jesse Eisenberg
has accepted him as the leader yeah it's good
character development these fellows here are
the ones left in the dark so let's see how
closely you are watching our show okay remember
when we were playing find the lady yes classic
switches and a few duplicates oh that's how we
switched the driver of the truck which took us
to a duplicate hanger oh okay that makes
sense so they plan to get caught how did
we get it to flock well we used fans and lights
and raid machines cool is this a movie trick we
needed to make sure that you would do exactly
what we needed you to do once you did catch us
my brother Chase there we go yeah so we we said I
he taught us that it's all about blind spots yeah
surprises well the reason I thought that was
convenient Watch the watch I'm wearing aware
of where you're watching and S oh I knew it
was going to come back he did it we showed
them everything how you kidnapped us to steal
the very thing that is in your pocket right now
whoops what you said you could use to adjust
markets manipulate governments these men destroy
people's lives yep tonight they are finally
stepping into into the light ah yeah Bravo
there's more inside me the horsemen are over
on them did you really think you were catching
them Road hold it right there do not move are
they going to start making out she's in cahoots
with them this contains everything I'm the same
man I've always been now you're playing the long
game yep nice like I want to become a
magician the very awesome yeah but it's
still never been revealed who the eye is
I still think it's his dad but could be
totally wrong yeah I have a lot to show
you look like a picture of Morgan Freeman I
thought for a sec oh it is what why are there
pictures of Morgan Freeman in there well we did
see Morgan Freeman walk by when he was a kid when
his dad was going down in the safe your father and
I were Partners yeah what I was a highe realist he
was the dreamy eyed idealist oh my goodness public
ey did go him only thing we didn't count on was it
going so wrong oh why didn't you ever say anything
shame guilt regret oh okay that makes sense too
look I put you in jail man what why didn't you
say something then well you know I was going to
but then you were so quick to show your personal
motivations that it spoiled the trick for me and
those Lobster Tales were good but when you came
back to myself you had let go of your 30e vettor
against me for your Horsemen ah you became the
leader and I knew it was my job to see to it
that he became the magician he was born to be the
Octor show was a setup to expose him to the public
jeez you were right about the horsemen they needed
to learn to work together like a single organism
wow what this guy was in on it too now I know
why you look so familiar You're The Horseman
aren't you oh my God like we did that whole yeah
that whole thing for you it was entertaining for
us it's okay you know the best tricks work on many
levels and the deepest one for me at least is this
moment right here I'm sorry Dyan even if he looks
different than the first film yeah it's your game
now you play it however you see fit oh he's the
eye now or so the head of the eye okay so um well
obviously we have a few questions good luck to you
all pay no attention to the curtain what's behind
the curtain it's his father I'm just I don't know
doubt he survived I got when you emerge I will be
there cuz one thing I believe in is an eye for
an ey for an ie wow very cool wow cool good job
John Chu Good twist oh Ed Solomon that oh Bo
is yakin that's the director of Remember the
Titans um Whoa by the way if you are listening
to this on Apple or spotifi if you can leave us
a review we'd really appreciate it it really does
help us rate it rate it rate it use those magic
fingers of yours to leave a review please uh I
really enjoyed it uh as the first film I mean
the thing I appre and the music by Brian Tyler
awesome as well uh the thing I appreciated the
most um obviously you know the magic is going to
entertain me the most of course but you know on
a deeper level uh I liked you know Mark ruffalo's
storyline just you know like becoming the leader
and then just the the theme of like Revenge I
mean that's that that was a theme in the first
film as well as this one too and then like trying
to become a leader as well and then you had uh
Jesse eisenberg's character you know he wanted
to be the leader as well and like what's best
for the group and the dynamic of the group so
those were the things I appreciated the most I
did definitely miss Isa Fischer not being in this
film because I really enjoyed her so much in the
first having said that I really did like Lizzie
Kaplan a lot she's she's such a great actress um
I and obviously I was so happy to get to see the
wizard himself Harry Potter in this film Daniel R
he was great in this as well I love seeing again
the pine of affection of approval from his father
I thought that was a nice little again there was
some really good twists uh oh oh okay I thought
we had I thought we had another little magic trick
up up their sleeves here for another scene but um
uh I have more to say but what did you think of
the film uh number one it said executive producer
or producer David freaking Copperfield do y'all
remember him he's magician and it came up and I'm
like oh my gosh see that so David Copperfield is
been helping them with all of these tricks in here
which makes complete sense the the stunts and the
tricks in this movie were fire like I mean insane
I mean I know they had a bunch in the first one
but I feel like this one really really delivered
and kept me on my toes uh which is great and I
also think that um like you said there there's
a lot of these characters that are pining after
like someone's approval which is why they're in
the Limelight and part of the horsemen right but
we saw it with um Jesse and with Mark Ruffalo too
at the same time thinking that like he might
eventually get to meet his dad but it turns
up to kind of be his enemy like Morgan Freeman
was is sort of the father figure that Mark may
have been pining after but is was actually
an enemy the whole time but pushing him in
the direction that he wanted him to go without
him being able to see it which is the only way
that Morgan Freeman would have been able to get
them into that position and I think it's awesome
that we discover that he's basically the eye and
handing it over to them which is like awesome I I
think it was well done but I again in my mind
I still think that was a complete redcon from
the first film like in my in my opinion when they
made the first film again this is just my opinion
I don't think they had an idea like okay when we
have this reveal of Mark ruffalo's character and
that Morgan Freeman is the guy that's trying to
you know stop The Magicians and expose them he's
going to eventually be the eye and I I don't
think that's again just my opinion if they did
then damn that was a Twist Beyond a Twist that
I could have really never seen I really do feel
it was a redcon that but again it was done in
a way that was satisfactory but it still felt
like a red conon but I mean the way they did it
I was like okay I can I can still buy it but um
again I I still liked it it was it was still a
pretty good twist uh I didn't see it coming cuz
you clearly heard 10,000 times I thought was
going to be the dad just because again that
one line at the beginning of I've got to trip uh
trick up my sleeve or whatever whatever the line
was so I really thought it was going to be that
um but then like they kind of did give you some
hints throughout the film that it could be Morgan
Freeman the the first scene they did was where he
did the uh when they were in the magic shop and
he did Escape I was like wait a second how was he
able to do to do that he's not a magician and then
it's like okay here's our little hints into uh you
know foreshadowing that he could be something
he that you don't think he is yeah I agree uh
which I like I didn't really necessarily see it
coming either but I thought this whole movie was
very very enjoyable yeah um I liked uh I liked
how they explained it like how did they get to
freaking China I'm like oh that that was cool how
they explained that yeah no for sure and then also
too when Woody harelson and his twin uh when
I said all right there's no way that he didn't
know he was going to uh like run into him the only
reason I said that uh was because I was wondering
why the three of them are doing like magic tricks
out in public and then he's specifically not he's
just walking and then he just runs into him so
that's why I came up with that when I said that
um but for me like even though all the magic was
was extremely entertaining my favorite thing was
that that long gated card thing that they were
doing uh when they were in that uh whatever that
Tech Lab or whatever that they were in just the
maneuvering and the I think you said best the
creativity in that scene it just almost even
though the camera was cutting a bit here and
there it just felt like one long tracking shot in
a way it was feel that way but I love the sense
of suspense in in that moment it just I really
felt like oh my God at any second it could going
it kept going like every second I thought it was
going to stop it just kept lingering but but I I
enjoyed it in a good way and those shots that I'm
like oh I don't think that that's special effects
they probably really did figure out how to do
slight of hand it could be obviously magician in
place especially from behind in the front it could
be a special effect or they could have learned how
to do that um I don't know probably it would be
great to see a behind the scenes of this film
of all of the films but this one specifically I
think it would be awesome as with that scene to
see what behind the scenes are and how they got it
shot and how um if they had a bunch of stand-ins
or how they got it done would be awesome to see
and their escapes I love when they do like with
the cards coming down and then into the rain into
the rain I was like what how do you even how do
you do how do you do that yeah I know crazy that
was really cool but wild yeah no uh good film um
and uh again we talked about also the theme
of uh Revenge also a big theme in this film
was letting go like obviously where Mark Ruffalo
had to put aside his uh again we say put aside
his revenge even though he'd gotten the guy Morgan
Freeman even though he was not responsible for uh
his father which we found out later but putting
aside what it uh you know his personal feelings
aside Mark ruffo's character uh with or Dylan's
character what had happened with his father and
Morgan Freeman and setting you know being a leader
because this is all about saving his team and I
appreciate that like it's good character moments
for me personally so yeah I liked it I also like
to see in the beginning how they they showed him
uh juggling both the FBI and being uh right at
the top almost being found out of that he is the
fifth Horseman um obviously I'm like oh great I'm
really glad that this script didn't have it as
though everyone at the FBI was just like we don't
know he's just a regular FBI guy cuz in crappier
movies they would um and right off the bat we see
him at the FBI going oh he's still juggling both
but that guy is already calling him out of like
I I see you and I know what you're doing which I
very much appreciate it I think this script and
the way that all of these movies are written and
this specifically also the way that they're shot
but uh the script is always really really smart
which I uh appreciate so much and very funny and
yeah I was going to say too I'm excited to see
what they do for the third film because it has
been announced that they are going to make a third
film Jesse Eisenberg has said that they're going
to start going very soon yeah so uh I mean because
it seems like Mark Ruffalo is now the the head of
the eye and uh all that so yeah that's awesome I
would give this an eight an eight eight Stars baby
say like a 7.5 or an eight out of 10 something
like that it's good stuff uh we love you guys this
fun fun is a blaster uh get to a magic shop learn
some magic we love you guys don't forget to leave
a like leave a comment do all the you subscribe
and we will see you guys on the next one bye